pee-yew tubers is Charlie George our
Martin just dropped a huge Theory bomb
so let's break this down we're right on
top of episode 1 so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be doing weekly episodes
and there's giveaway stuff that I'll
talk about at the end of the video but
you probably heard about the interview
that George R Martin did in the last
week where he reminisced about a lot of
the big changes between the books the
show the characters that are alive in
dead in those relative places but while
he was doing it he revealed a key detail
that confirmed a big theory that people
had about people that are brought back
from the dead both ice and fire so
you're talking about people that are
raised by red priests you're talking
about the knight King as well as Craster
sons that he turns into White Walkers
and the dead that he raises so risen by
ice risen by fire he talks a little bit
about beric Dondarrion Lady Stoneheart
how he's dead in the books in service of
Lady Stoneheart but he's still alive on
the TV show so the quotes is setting
everyone off as where he says his
memories are fading he's got all these
scars he's becoming more and more
physically hideous because he's not a
living human anymore his heart isn't
beating his blood isn't flowing in his
veins he's a white but a white animated
by fire instead of ice and now we're
back to the whole Fire and Ice thing so
Martin is saying that beric Dondarrion
is essentially the same thing is one of
these skeletal white walkers with all
this necrotic tissue hanging off them
it's just that he's risen by the power
of the red God which means that anyone
who is raised from the dead by a red
priest is also a fire white to certain
degree like he says that beric
Dondarrion is slowly losing his memory
is fading so there's a sliding scale of
how much white you are so back during
season 4 a good example is that Ray
Harryhausen looking skeleton white that
attacks them as they're getting ready to
go into the three-eyed Ravens tree that
would be maximum white you literally
have almost no tissue on you left you
have no memories of your former life
you're just a skeleton running around
animated by magic so that would mean
someone like John Snow who's only been
risen from the dead once even though the
way he died was pretty gruesome is more
human than beric Dondarrion or closer to
human but it also implies that his heart
isn't beating and there's no blood in
his veins even though they haven't
directly addressed that on the tee
vo there are a lot of differences in the
way the TV show has chosen to treat
magic and mythology that Martin uses in
the books one of the biggest examples is
Daenerys being fireproof Martin has said
in the past that she's only fireproof
back during season one because blood
magic was in play Mirri Maz Duur the
sacrifice of her baby all that together
made her fireproof but on the show Dan
and Dave have chosen to say that
Daenerys is fireproof all the time
so there's always questions when the
show does things like that it's only
going to get worse in season 7 because
of all the big magic in play but now
that we know that Jon Snow is
essentially a fire white to a certain
degree it also throws a lot of endgame
theories into question because whether
you believe that Jon Snow deserves to
sit on the Iron Throne whether or not
you believe that he's going to become
the new night King it is going to be
some big twist on Fire and Ice whether
or not you think that he's going to have
a baby
with Daenerys because there's a lot of
book evidence that that might be the
direction those characters are headed at
the end of the day I do think of the
show even though it's diverged from the
books a lot will circle back around and
the books will end at a similar point
it's just that all the stuff between now
and endgame is going to be a lot
different of all the theories that I've
had in the past now I'm thinking more
and more that Jon Snow will not end up
on the Iron Throne no matter what
regardless of what he gets involved in
with Daenerys regardless of what
relationship they might have which I'll
address in a second because I do think
that they will be together they'll bang
however you want to say it they will
probably get together before the story
is over and it has something to do with
Daenerys supposedly being barren but
endgame for Jon Snow is almost assured
now that he won't end up on the Iron
Throne whether or not he outright dies
fighting the night King and has failed
to be brought back or whether or not
he's actually forced to become the next
night King and help guard the realm from
the other side like become the night
king so that you can control the army of
the Dead even though it would imply that
he'd also lose some of his memories -
there's also the sliding scale of being
a white so there's so many new questions
but changing Jon Snow and Daenerys
theories now it almost seems like now
they're setting up a big twist where Jon
Snow does get to have that happy moment
but when Martin says the ending is
bittersweet he has to leave Daenerys but
you know
big new twist child of Ice and Fire
actually winds up being their child even
though John Stowe himself is technically
the child of Ice and Fire
you may have heard Jon Snow Daenerys
baby theories in the past but during
book 1 Neary master tells Daenerys that
she's barren she can't have any more
children after the ordeal that she goes
through with blood magic trying to bring
Khal Drogo back that's it that's the end
of it but the interesting thing is is
that a couple books later it's implied
that she has her period meaning that she
might be fertile again so it's almost
like the story is trying to say that
she'll only become pregnant through some
magical means involving Jon Snow in his
special magical blood like there's so
many special things about those two
characters so many mythical prophecy
things that seem to be converging like
they had their relationships with
Ygritte she had Khal Drogo it's been a
couple of years now maybe they're ready
to move on so they eventually get
together Daenerys becomes pregnant with
the child of Ice and Fire and then Jon
Snow goes to meet his new fate because
regardless of who you feel deserves to
sit on the Iron Throne it's implied that
most of the main players will wind up
dying most people won't make it out of
this story so it'll be the next
generation that will inherit this new
spring that they're trying to bring back
like dream of spring the flawed people
now like Jaime Lannister won't live to
see the future that they're trying to
create so you have potential Jon Snow
Daenerys baby child of Ice and Fire
sitting on the Iron Throne you have
people like baby Sam on the TV show but
if Jon Snow is part fire white you do
wonder if he doesn't have blood flowing
in his veins in his heart isn't beating
can you also have a child I think the
idea is probably just like Daenerys it's
implied that he can't until great magic
is in play again like when they come
together so let me know in the comments
what do you think about the idea of Jon
Snow being a white animated by fire and
what that might say about his potential
ending on the TV show and how that might
play out in his relationship with
Daenerys or any potential relationship
I know separately a lot of you are
referencing that Kit Harington interview
that he did this is the clip where he
talks about the fake scenes that they
did and how long before you will go back
to work shooting the show ah well you
see I mean not the stuff of slides right
I don't know if I'm back in will you
have the scene with Daenerys Targaryen
can you tell us that what I can say
about this season is that we had a lot
of we had a lot of paparazzi following
us around yes when we were in Spain okay
but we did fake some scenes we are we've
put together people in situations where
we knew the paparazzi was around so they
take photos and that will get on the
internet
- fake scenes severely think what a pain
in your ass that is I mean really no I
can't tell you anything all right all I
can tell is that what you might have
seen on the Internet anyone who follows
it is that might not be true it might be
true but it also might be true and you
might be just saying that to throw us
off yeah yeah how many fake scenes were
you personally involved in 3 3 315 315
how many hours of those fake scenes take
to shoot about 5 hours each it really
the thing about that is that his
comments are really hard to take at face
value because he spent all of last year
lying to try and throw people off oh no
I'm not coming back he went on all these
talk shows said the exact same thing
he lied to everyone even though we saw
him back in Belfast quite a bit so it's
like okay you're very clearly right next
to the set what are you doing here if
you're not filming Game of Thrones
because you're not filming something
else then he was spotted on set so it
was like okay very clearly you're part
of the season we know you're coming back
what's the deal that's like the new
thing in Hollywood is just bold-faced
lie to the camera to everyone that's
what the studio tells them to do to like
they want to maintain a certain era of
secrecy because so many people go in
camps and said so you see all kinds of
pictures the thing is is the amount of
faked scenes that he said they filmed is
actually pretty plausible so we'll see
when we get to the episodes I think
there may be a few things where they
tried to mess with people just remember
there are only seven episodes so it's
not like they're going to drag their
feet in getting to the really big WTF
moments in there's another big theory
that people were talking about this past
week to George R Martin may have
secretly finished winds of winter I
think that's not true now because he's
come out since then and said that he's
not going to be doing any more
television writing any more television
until he finishes winds of winter
there was another H
vo TV series based on non Game of
Thrones IP that he owned that was being
developed and he was a part of it he's
an executive producer so people are like
if you're working on this other TV show
does that mean that you're done with
winds of winter because that was the
whole reason that you stopped working on
Game of Thrones a lot so I think his
comments after the fact we're just made
in response just to quiet people down a
little bit so what's going to happen is
because this was kind of unexpected my
death predictions video will post Sunday
morning then I'll post my episode 1
video there's a new round of the
giveaway for the HBO now subscription
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
that'll be new each week throughout the
season so I'll just remind people when I
post my episode 1 video while you wait
for everything you can click here for my
episode 1 preview and you can click here
for all my other season 7 videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you